buonasera
tutti io sono
anzi sono un illustratore e
concretamente disegni per giornali e
riviste in generale per il mondo
editoriale e pubblicitario e dunque il
mio mio lavoro ha strettamente bisogno
di internet e delle tecnologie digitali
e diciamo che il mio lavoro e passa da
uno schermo nel senso che non solo per
come viene prodotta materialmente
l'immagine perché io lavoro e
concretamente con software digitali e ma
anche per tutto quello che riguarda il
discorso di rapporto con il con il
cliente con il committente e al giorno
d'oggi è avere una connessione internet
e avere un'email è la cosa necessaria e
sufficiente per avere un rapporto
lavorativo di questo tipo telefono e ci
si può sentire per telefono ma anche
superfluo e ovviamente vedersi di
persona con i clienti
quando si tratta di avere migliaia di
chilometri di distanza è impossibile è
dunque fondamentale anche perché il
proprio sito web
e i propri social media sono il
biglietto da visita di chi fa un lavoro
creativo in digitale e dunque parliamo
di schermi quindi il mio lavoro nasce da
uno schermo e che cos'è uno schermo in
in italiano è qualcosa che che mostra
qualcosa che rende visibile appunto come
uno schermo di un computer o di un di
una sala di un cinema rende visibile
qualcosa ma appunto in italiano e anche
qualcosa che che protegge che crea una
barriera difensiva tra un ambiente e un
altro e questa barriera
come ogni
come ogni schermo e è anche un filtro è
anche una mediazione impedisce un
contatto diretto tra due ambienti o due
interlocutori
ecco e gli schermi si parla anche
nell'articolo che dà il titolo a questo
all'evento di oggi che forchette
internet of things milan in senato
people apparso sul guardian e l'anno
scorso in cui le due autrici jenny judge
e giulia powell e mettevano in nota come
tutti i tentativi finora fatti di creare
una gadgettistica per realtà aumentata e
avevano in qualche modo bisogno della
presenza di uno schermo anche quelli più
sofisticati integrati alla nostra
persona come google plus è l'apple watch
ad esempio e come tutte le cose che
abbisognano di uno schermo e impediscono
impedivano in qualche modo un accesso un
accesso diretto con il mondo reale o
almeno per l'esperienza a cui siamo
abituati ne siamo abituati come uomini a
un'interazione molto intuitiva e
istintiva con con la realtà che ci
circonda con con gli oggetti ma anche
con con le persone dunque in questa
realtà fatta di di schermi di oggetti
smart ed i rapporti umani mediati da dal
virtuale e secondo me quando si parla di
di fare comunicazione in questo caso
visuale ma in generale in tutti i tipi
di comunicazione e c'è bisogno di creare
un contenuto che vada che vada oltre in
questo schermo che in qualche modo lo
buchi cioè che faccia direttamente a
fare leva nell'immaginario delle persone
e che in qualche modo questi contenuti
prendano una vita propri iniziano
iniziano a camminare con le gambe di chi
li riceve
e questo implica il far crescere nuove
idee e far crescere nuove intuizioni
nuove riflessioni anche
e anche opposte e contrarie a quelle e
dell'input iniziale e dunque quindi se
non è più che di di oggetti più che di
più che di gadget è importante al giorno
d'oggi concentrarsi più sui contenuti
più sui sulle idee e sulle e
sull'esperienza che la comunicazione
buona mirata efficace deve creare e qui
si parla di una direzione umanistica si
parla di un impegno filosofico anche
politico in senso lato immorale qualcosa
che metta al centro l'uomo la persona e
le sue esigenze e ecco questo è il se
come il passo per creare una internet of
people piuttosto che una internet of
things internet mi piace vederlo come un
cemento che tiene tiene insieme degli
individui che altrimenti farebbero
fatica a connettersi tra di loro e come
proprio come in cemento e serve a
costruire degli degli edifici sempre più
alti sempre più e sempre più popolati
però in ultima analisi sono le persone
che devono riempire di contenuti questa
internet riempire di contenuti questi
edifici renderli vivibili e abitabili
quindi penso sia questo il senso di
internet of people
adesso passerò a farvi vedere una cosa
al computer
scusate non è qualche difficoltà tecnica
ok fare musica
grazie